hi there steve kaufman here um
again in the new room hopefully with
better sound and if i can do things to
make the sound better i will do so i'm
looking into different things
um but today i want to talk about and
remember if you like these videos please
subscribe give me a like if you're so
inclined
today i want to talk about the
frustrations of language learning
and i have talked about this before and
because there are
moments of frustration we all have have
them at different times
it comes up because i had a conversation
with a fellow polyglot whose name is
robin and we may even put this uh
interview up here uh in a week or so
and uh he was interested in the subject
of the sort of um
the language learning plateau where we
feel
we're not making any progress
one of the people i spoke to referred to
the early engagement with a new language
as being the honeymoon period when we're
all excited
and then the plateau is that long period
where
we feel we're not making any progress
robin felt that the language learning uh
plateau largely had to do with people
who didn't speak as well as they would
like to speak
but i have a slightly different
perspective on the language learning
plateau where for me it's all about
you know
my comprehension where i feel that once
i'm past the early stage then
it seems that i'm it's just so difficult
to acquire
these low frequency words and to get
used to the language and to understand
better when i listen so for me it's more
of a comprehension based thing i feel
that
that that middle period
uh is one of just a long long road of
getting to where you understand things
better but so if we look at frustration
in fact there is frustration at every
level
again if we have that initial the
honeymoon period where we discover a new
language
and then we have that long intermediate
period where we are basically trying to
accumulate more words and and get the
brain more used to the language so that
we understand better some people are
worried about how they speak at that
level i'm not
but even in the advanced level
even at that level where we now
understand well and we have a large
vocabulary there's another type of
frustration and that is that we continue
to make the same mistakes and we can't
seem to
you know like in my slavic languages i
just can't seem to
nail the cases and i hear if i was
listening to our political i just i'm
curious because in canada we're going to
have a a conservative party
uh
leadership uh you know
contest
because the previous conservative uh
leader uh resigned
and so i wanted to hear how well they
speak french and so i listened to uh two
of them in french
uh peter mckay and aaron o'toole
and i mean it's just appalling like the
especially gender which is hard to nail
i know in russian cases are hard to nail
gender is hard to nail there's no gender
in english so how do you get used to
saying it properly so that's a
frustration obviously
perhaps these people understand well i
don't know but they have trouble
producing the language correctly so
to summarize again the frustration at
the beginning period is
and this was the case in my arabic and
also in other languages it's just
unless it says a language very similar
like if i
if i go if i try to study serbo croatian
there's no frustration there because
it's so similar to other slavic
languages that i've learned it's just a
matter of picking up a slightly
different vocabulary or a certain amount
of different vocabulary and just letting
the brain get used to it so there's no
frustration there but if you go into
something completely different like
persian or arabic you know like when
will i ever get used to this writing
system the letters mean different things
i confuse one letter with the other
um
i can't understand it i listen 10 15
times i can't understand it so those are
the frustrations at the beginning stage
and there the only solution is just to
keep going and my own strategy is to
listen often to the same material i have
to get a toehold on the language but it
is frustrating when you listen to
something for the tenth time and the
same spot it just is just noise even
though you've read it and you know
theoretically what words are supposed to
be there and you listen to it for the
10th or even 15th time
and you just don't understand it so
that's frustrating
so those are the frustrations at the
beginning and the frustration of of
trying to grab onto some vocab
vocabulary and try to get
some sense of the language
so those are the frustrations but
there you just work your way through
them if you are motivated enough
uh in the uh you know to learn the
language
motivated by the thought of wow i'll be
able to listen to arabic one day and
i'll be listening to their podcast and
i'll understand what they're saying and
if they sh on twitter i see videos of
demonstrations in iraq and they're all
shouting something and i'll be able to
understand that and i even follow people
on twitter in persian and arabic and
i'll be able to read what they're saying
and even as i'm in the early stages
those are things that motivate me i just
have to stay with it so that's the first
stage
now the second stage
the frustrations in that middle period
for some people it's it's the
frustration that they can't
speak very well
um but to me i'm not mo i'm not
concerned about that like i am going to
have a conversation in persian tomorrow
uh i haven't spoken version
gosh knows how long i have no idea how i
i'll do it doesn't matter i know that
i've been listening and increasing my
knowledge my my sense of the language i
can now go through lessons at link and i
can kind of work my way i understand it
i i can even
guess better now at the pronunciation of
of words which isn't always obvious from
the you know the way it's written
but it is frustrating because
you know i i have to read through it and
then i listen to it and i kind of
understand
but it's not yet comfortable to me the
comfort stage is where i can just take a
podcast listen to it
go with it and and have it run through
my brain and i notice certain things and
yeah there's some words i don't know but
the overall sense is enjoying the
language
here in the middle stage i'm not yet
enjoying it but i don't have any
illusions about how well i'm going to
speak so my frustration is that
because the new words that i'm adding
are all now
much lower frequency than the words at
the beginning stage that it's just going
to take a long time
just pounding the language in my brain
picking up words as i go
you know
every page on link has you know i'll
re-read a lesson that i've read before
so there could be 20 yellow words there
i read through i have to look every one
of them up
kind of
you know
driving it into my brain
and even as i read through and then i
listen to it it's all helping me get
used to the language but it's not
comfortable in the sense that it's not
immediate comprehension so that's a bit
frustrating but
in the final stage
that's the stage where i feel i want to
try to clean up my grammar because now
if i read a grammar book
and like in russian i would read a
grammar book in russian but i've read it
all before but somehow
that's the stage where i want to try to
focus on
uh
areas where
you know i have trouble
i have trouble
speaking correctly i i don't have
trouble throwing the words together but
i have trouble throwing the words
together correctly and that gets back to
my to our canadian politicians english
speakers who
struggle to say with gender you kind of
have to listen
notice the gender
save phrases repeat those phrases so
that when those phrases come up
you're gonna naturally just spit out the
correct gender you can't try to think
about gender while you're speaking i
can't think about cases
you do a little bit you do a little bit
think of gender because there are
certain endings that are going to say is
masculine or feminine but in french
that's not always reliable
but typically in russian if i get those
cases that i managed to produce
correctly is because i have a certain
momentum i have a certain rhythm certain
phrases where
the case is there because that's just
naturally what comes out but until you
reach the stage where you can do that it
is frustrating and the advantage of
doing the grammar at the advanced stage
is that you have seen it all you've
whatever they refer to in terms of a
grammar rule it's something it describes
something that you're familiar with and
now you just have to try to focus in on
it get used to it get the brain used to
it and of course this is all frustrating
now there could be other frustrations
some people say that even when they're
fairly advanced and they can listen to
something say an audiobook but if they
watch a movie and things are happening
quickly or if they're in a conversation
with five people
that it's frustrating that they don't
understand it better but i think
you know
to summarize the only solution to all of
these frustrations is to continue
that's the only solution
you just have to keep doing what you're
doing you have to speak more you have to
listen more you have to read more
so you have to want to do it you have to
put in the time you have to have the
confidence that you will eventually get
there and and not allow the frustrations
to create negative feelings
towards what you're doing towards the
learning process towards the language
because everything that's negative is
gonna slow you
down whereas
reminding yourself how much you have
already achieved
where you were six months earlier a year
earlier any of these positive things
that sort of reinforce your your belief
that you're doing something worthwhile
that's what you have to go to
in order to
press through
and and and just get that little bit
better bearing in mind that you will
never be perfect so there will always be
some sense of frustration that you're
not as good as you would like to be
okay thank you for listening bye for now